ich habe noch nie gesagt mir ist
schlecht damit ich kann nicht mit jemand
anderem nach hause gehen können so leute
jetzt kommt die bei das tageslicht ja
selber jetzt geht es endlich kommen zu
einem neuen video leute wir machen heute
wm titel gesehen hat eine ich habe noch
nie party edition das heißt wir spielen
ich habe noch nie das kennt ihr alle
aber mit ganz speziellen fragen zu
sachen die bei uns schon auf partys
passiert sind oder ihr wollt uns leute
heute schon das ist heute nicht alleine
mich gehen sondern um einen absoluten
partner in crime band und feiern hier in
köln geht werte applaus bitte für ja wie
gesagt wir haben wie immer ich habe noch
nie und ich habe zettel und nieren und
twitter frage gestellte gehe jetzt durch
und legen los und die wahl will das
tageslicht kommen leute und ihr werdet
wissen was man beim feiern lieber nicht
machen sollte ich habe noch nie auf
einer party auf die tanzfläche gekonnt
und 21 kranke lydia wie kannst du so
drögen das ist tatsächlich eine sache
die ist mir glaube ich echt nicht
passiert also mit schon einiges passiert
in meinem leben aber das ist schon
krankhaft i fucking tanzfläche ist ja
wobei ich habe noch nie so viel alkohol
getrunken dass ich dachte ich wäre ihr
fahrzeug oder gegenstand
ok ok gerettet leute gerettet als er den
gedanken an wie du sagst du ich hatte
noch nie das böse aber so böse leute
sehr sich viele substanzen drehen die
eventuell das verhalten von menschen
verändern können ihr wisst zum beispiel
geht es ja um flüssige substanzen oder
vielleicht auch andere drucksachen weise
muss man sagen dass man so von alkohol
eigentlich keine so störung bekommt dass
man denkt man sogar
es gibt aber andere substanzen manche
vielleicht natürlich angebaut wurde es
durchaus mal passieren die kern aber das
war nicht die frage ich habe noch nie so
viel getrunken dass ich mich jungen aufs
maul gelegt habe
ich sehe das passiert ist mehr als
einmal passiert ich habe lange gefreut
und wir sie kennengelernt der partie
sehr betrunken habe ganz auf den
geflogen bin von einem nächsten tag hat
er bin ich darauf gewartet dann war mir
auch immer befreundet
ich weiß bis heute nicht wo ich
überhaupt einen namen haben wir
natürlich jetzt eine geschichte leute
wie ich die geschichten über die mir
glaubt dass die in keinerlei
zusammenhang mit irgendwelchen dingen
die man eventuell über den mund aufnimmt
zu tun hat vor allem nicht mit
flüssigkeiten und zwar seit ich mal in
einem club hatten vorher versucht in
heidelberg weil das in der bar auf
marker und habe mir das geschehen so
angeschaut welche davor ich gucke mir
einfach antworten ja auf einmal wie soll
ich sagen kam der boden auf mich zu
dieser these aber nicht so moment mal
das stimmt irgendwas wenig zwei
gleichgewichtssinn funktion mein kopf da
irgendwas passiert weil das liegt daran
dass ich gerade schon eben umkippt
mit diesem hocke umgekippt und auf der
tanzfläche gelangen da ist gar nichts
hast du schon mal betrunken eine
polizistin oder polizist dann gemacht
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt alles bisher schärfen
hat wir wollen es nicht zu extremen so
oder so machen oder so andere sachen
deswegen versuche ich das jetzt mal
anders zu beschreiben und zwar ich hatte
noch nie die sache nach der storch kommt
oder einen die sache die das stück kommt
mit dem mund bei der party oder club 3 2
1 ich weiß dass sie dem körper ist klein
rot größtenteils meistens enthaltsam
beschränke mich darauf die
briefmarkensammlung der jeweiligen
gastgeberin zu begutachten du ja ich bin
noch nicht fremd gegangen als ich auf
einer party war bei mir ist einfach so
für mich interessiert sich niemand
deswegen dich sowieso meistens allein in
der ecke und schaue mir die wandern
ich habe noch nie auf einer party
youtube geschaut was du musst die
facetten meine videos sortieren
hassprediger ich habe noch nie jemanden
geküsst den ich nicht kannte
was heißt nicht kennen
heute kann seine finger zu schauen dass
ihr noch nicht mehr weiter sein produkt
so passiert dann seid ihr jetzt schon
mal vorgewarnt wie soll man sagen ich
würde sagen das ist mal was man dass er
ein obama ist schon ein bisschen getan
sein was nur sagen mal was ja nur was
das erste mal mit holen dass man davor
gequatscht wird über zuvor aufenthalt
haben fassen
16 uhr das retro ein wort mit der person
gewechselt hast kleine rote dazu nicht
so dass ich schwöre ohne dass sich ein
wort mit der person geredet haben ich
glaube nein raus erzählt mir deine story
ist als wir mal von 40 us dollar eines
neues wissen schon mal stockbesoffen
auto gefahren und dass die ganz klare
antwort leute ja leute wirklich das geht
gar nicht hat die sache es leute wenn
ihr auto fahren im stadtverkehr
teilnimmt habt ihr immer auch andere
menschen um mich herum und werde da
einfach betroffen seien deswegen
irgendwann stirbt verzeichne deswegen
habe ich das selbst nie gemacht und wird
sondern machen ich habe noch nie gesagt
mir ist schlecht damit ich heim nicht
mit jemanden der nach hause gehen konnte
jetzt kommt die bei tageslicht macht da
kennst du das nicht man generell wenn du
auch keine keinen bock auf die party mal
hast du denn noch gehen willst da gibt's
ja auch manchmal andere sondern warum
jetzt gerade gehen möchte in dem moment
ich persönlich bin eigentlich vor
rücksichtsvoll und ich finde es schwer
alle leute sozusagen soja verpiss dich
scheiße ich deswegen habe ich meistens
immer ich die übrigen im dispo maxx
deswegen manchmal muss man der story
einfach aufbauen so heißt eine gute
story ist glaubt dass die leute mit
weniger zur nach hause gehen dass du
getan hast rezepte schlechtes
geschrieben haben ist von diesem video
leute wir haben heute die stories
erzählt war für euch raus gehauen dann
wie jannis dabei seien die welt hat
gelernt und denke dass das gespann dies
sind aber jetzt habe ich vergessen aber
ihr könnt jetzt auf jeden fall eine
folge was das geht ab und vertraut
klicken will kommen wir da hin und bis
zum nächsten mal nordrhein und zeigt die
site